So the answer is the only thing that search depends on about crawler, is how the
index and ranks are represented. It doesn't depend on how they're created as
long as they represent the web quater piece in the way search expects, search
will work correctly. It doesn't depend on how the links are extracted and we saw
that we can change the crawler to use beautiful soup. We replace to get our
links procedure in a way use beautiful soup, but we didn't have to change
anything about search when we did that. It doesn't depend in crawler on what add
to index does in crawler. In fact it doesn't even depend on add to index
existing, none of the names defined in crawler are visible in the search because
there's no import here. It doesn't depend on how the ranks are computed, as long
as the values in this ranks object that's passed into search, correctly
represents something about how popular a page is. But it does depend on this
one. On how the index and ranks are represented and that's a big complex
dependancy.